okay
feels lighter than a normal oreo package
see these are vanilla but that's just
like regular oreo flavor right
oh this is like a little
japanese moon pie definitely smaller
than a normal oreo it's not that soft i
always eat oreos by opening them up
[Music]
it's not happening
tasted like bread they give you like the
satisfaction of a cookie and a cupcake
it definitely doesn't taste like an oreo
at all these oreos are pretty damn good
men's pocky why are they men's it's kind
of like a cigarette packet not that i
know like i want to smoke this i'm not a
smoker don't encourage smoking maybe
this was originally designed for
quitting smoking like you carry this
around your pocket you can have a snack
every time you get the urge this
packaging looks just like in my cologne
pop out your pocky men's at the bar
all the ladies heads turn does it look
like a man it's little pretty small for
a manly pocky if you ask me
it's just dark chocolate yeah it's like
a breadstick dipped in chocolate you
know women can handle some dark
chocolate too you know
i love this already so we're eating tree
trunks little bunny that's running away
i wonder what he's saying he's like stop
deforestation i wonder if they have a
separate candy line that is like
cut down trees
it feels like i'm playing a video game
you know when you like open a video game
and it gives you instructions on what to
do
oh
it's kind of like a box of tissues oh my
god
look at that the the tree rings and
center let's try this out there's a
little there's a little flavor there
chocolate looks rather a really rich
graham cracker can they just sell the
tree version before he's cut it
down black black hard looks like chewing
gum caffeine kind of sounds like a
clinton tarantino movie black black card
oh yeah
and it comes with a little pad of paper
what's this is this for you to like
write your feelings about the chewing
gum it's not for eating right
it's not breathing it is in fact black
and hard
oh man
it's like i'm outside in winter but it
starts to hurt in the back of your
throat that's just like vicks vapor rub
in a gum they're meant for when you spit
out your gum
which i'm just gonna do
you can wrap it
and throw this away
oh yes
[Music]
you